كانت تلفزيون الرسميه الصيني قد اعلن ان
الجيش الصيني اجرى مناورات صاروخيه
بالذخيره الحيه في اقليم ماشين جيانغ
غربيه البلاد هذا وعرضت وسائل الاعلام
الصينيه صورا قالت انها لتلك المناورات
دون ذكر تفاصيل او تحديد تاريخ اجرائها
وتظهر الصور تدريبات بتاخير الحيه
وعمليه اطلاق صواريخ والتحركات لعربه
مدرعه وياتي الاعلان عن هذه التدريبات
الصاروخيه الجديده بعد ثلاثه ايام من
انهاء او الانتهاء المناورات البحريه التي
اجرتها الصين حول جزيره تايوان
معنا الان من بجيم مراسله الجزيره شيماء
جويئي شيماء نرحب بك ونتساءل كيف قابلت
الصين هذه التحذيرات الاوروبيه من تصعيد
التوتر في مضيق تايوان على اراضيها
نعم ازدهار عبد القادر اليوم كان هنالك
مؤتمر صحفي مشترك بين وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه ووزير الخارجيه الصيني تشينغا
وكان هنالك حضور لافت
لملفات المتصاعده في المنطقه خلال الاونه
الاخيره لو لخصنا ما جاء في المؤتمر لثلاث
محاور رئيسيه كان هنالك تناول بطبيعه
الحال للعلاقات الثنائيه بين المانيا
والصين مزيد من تطوير هذه العلاقات وتعزيز
التبادلات التجاريه والاقتصاديه بين
الجانبين خلال المرحله المقبله وكان هنالك
حضور لافت للملف التايواني الجانب
الالماني اكد ان المانيا والدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي كافه تتابع بقلق التوترات
المتصاعده في مضيق تايوان هنالك حث من
الجانب
الالماني
للصين وتايوان على خفض التصعيد عبر مضيق
تايوان تحدثت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه عن
ان 50% من التجاره عالميه تمر عبر مضيق
تايوان لذلك من الاهميه بمكان بحسب وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه لكل دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي ودول العالم الحفاظ على حريه
الملاحه والامن والاستقرار في المنطقه
تحدثت ايضا عن ان 70% او ما لا يقل عن 70%
من منتوجات اشباه الموصلات او الرقائق
الالكترونيه فائقه الدقه يتم انتاجها في
جزيره تايوان
من الانتاج العالمي لهذه الرقائق او اشباه
الموصلات تمر ايضا عبر مضيق تايوان هنالك
اعتماد كلي من دول العالم ودول الاتحاد
الاوروبي وتحديدا المانيا ايضا على هذه
الرقائق وعلى مضيق تايوان والامن
والاستقرار فيه كان هنالك ايضا ازدهار
حضور لافت لي ملف الحرب في اوكرانيا تحدثت
وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه عن ان المانيا
تدعو الصين الى ممارسه نفوذها القوي على
روسيا من اجل وقف الحرب في اوكرانيا قالت
بانه ليس هنالك دوله في العالم لديها نفوذ
اكثر من الصين على روسيا وقالت بان بيجين
مسؤوله من قبل كل دول العالم بان تقوم
بدورها وتفيا بالتزاماتها فيما يتعلق بوقف
التصعيد في الاراضي الاوكرانيه قالت بان
هنالك حاجه ملحه اليوم لوقف الحرب في
اوكرانيا وقالت ايضا بان على بيجين ان
تمارس الضغطا كبيرا على بوتا خلال المرحله
المقبله من اجل وقف التصعيد من جانبه وزير
الخارجيه الصيني حاول ان يتوسع كثيرا في
ملف تايوان باعتبار ان تايوان جزء لا
يتجزا من اراضي الصين بحسب تعبيره قال
ايضا بانها ملف شان الداخلي محض وقال ايضا
بانه بالنسبه للصين فان اي دوله في العالم
بما فيها المانيا ودول الاتحاد الاوروبي
ان ارادت ان تحترم مبدا الصين واحده فيجب
الا تدافع عن استقلال تايوان واكد ايضا ان
الصين تحث على محادثات السلام فيما يتعلق
بالملف الاوكراني شيماء شو قي شكرا جزيلا
لك